foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
women from the Philippines led by women
workers and women from the toiling
classes are out on the streets calling
for higher wages calling for decent work
calling for a free and accessible public
support services and calling and
asserting our right and our freedom of
Association and the right to organize in
order to fight for our demands
[Music]
we're seeing the widest gender pay Gap
we are seeing an unprecedented
unprecedented uh increase in the number
of women workers who are in informal
work without any protection without any
labor standards to govern their rights
as workers and agreement